[Musik]
sehr geehrte damen und herren ich
begrüße sie herzlich zum pressegespräch
mit verteidigungsministern klaudia
tanner mit der frauenministerin susanne
rapp und hauptmann christine hofer und
nicht auf die verteidigungsministerien
ersuchen zu beginnen
vielen dank sehr geehrte frau
bundesministerin sehr geehrter herr
hauptmann sehr geehrte damen und herren
der medien
es ist eine woche her ein ganz
besonderer tag eine große ehre und
freude als ich die erste frau in der
geschichte unseres heeres zur regiments
kommandantin er nennen durfte wir haben
mit frau oberstleutnant krutzler eine
einsatz erfahrene frauen eine sehr
wichtige führungsfunktionen unseres
heeres gestellt ein sehr wichtiger
schritt aber wenn man sich den
frauenanteil ansieht dann liegt der bei
vier prozent in unserem her und
dementsprechend sind gerade in der
führungsstruktur noch wenige frauen
vertreten ich freue mich daher immer
wieder wenn wir pionierinnen für viele
frauen bekommen dem muss muss aber noch
einiges folgen und daher ist es mir auch
eine besondere freude die frau hauptmann
an meiner an unserer seite zu haben
wir haben vieles zu tun in enger
abstimmung und in zusammenarbeit mit
frau bundesministerin raab haben wir
unglaublich starkes maßnahmenpaket
geschnürt was sind nun die maßnahmen
wir wollen zum einen mit informations
offizieren offizier innen verstärkt auch
frauen ansprechen
wir werden die fitness app zur
vorbereitung auf die durchaus
vorhandenen sportlichen tests
weiterentwickeln
wir implementieren derzeit den
mentorinnen programm für junge
soldatinnen denen dann eben mehr
eine kameradinnen an die seite gestellt
werden
wir werden vier sein neues referat in
unserem ressort schaffen dass an einer
steigerung der soldatinnen anteils im
bundesheer arbeiten soll
und wir legen einen sehr starken fokus
auf dem medien präsenz von frauen in
unserer werbearbeit und ich freue mich
heute wirklich sehr dass wir ihnen erste
ergebnisse davon noch zeigen können mit
dem girls day als kickoff starten wir
eine werbekampagne unter dem titel unser
heer ihre chance die frauen in den
mittelpunkt rückt und zeigen soll wie
vielfältig die jobs in unserem her sind
das geht von der sanitäterin bis eben
zur militärpolizisten und ich freue mich
ihnen im anschluss dann ein video
präsentieren zu dürfen welches im rahmen
unserer kampagne auf diversen kanälen
verbreitet wird
hier sehen sie jetzt sofort die sich ist
[Musik]
es ist mir ein bedürfnis mich zu
bedanken bei den soldatinnen detail
dieser kampagne sind an erster stelle
und dann als pionierinnen so oft
vorangehen es ist mir aber auch ein
besonderes bedürfnis mich bei dir zu
bedanken liebe frau bundesministerin für
die sehr konstruktive zusammenarbeit
genfer hauptmann ihnen insbesondere für
die bereitschaft dass sie uns einen
vertieften einblick aufgeben werden in
ihren persönlichen werdegang dankeschön
an die frau ministerin suchen wie die
ausführungen ja schönen nachmittag ich
möchte mich bei bundesministerin dana
ganz herzlich bedanken für die
gemeinsame initiative dass man das
bisher als berufsfeld attraktiver für
frauen macht uns eine wirklich ein ganz
zentraler gedanke nämlich jener dass man
als mädchen das junge frau einfach alles
werden kann was man möchte
das ist unser großes anliegen und
unabhängig davon ob ein berufsbild jetzt
alles irgendwie männerdominiert das
berufsfeld gilt oder nicht
einem mädchen sollen alle branchen offen
stehen und alle träume sollen sich
erfüllen können und einfach alle chancen
die das berufsleben auch bietet sollen
mädchen auch offen stehen was braucht es
dazu damit wir diesen gedanken
vorantreiben es braucht zum einen um
vorbilder starke role models die zeigen
wie es geht und wie bereichernd und
einfach toll ein lebensweg vielleicht
auch im berufs wegen einer sogenannten
männerdominierten branche auch sein kann
ich durfte es frauenministerin laufen so
tolle vorbilder kennenlernen heute die
frau hauptmann beispielsweise ich durfte
auch bereits die erste offizieren im
bundesheer kennenlernen die fahrsperren
star andy o wir wären auch heute noch
die frau wachtmeister bachmeier kennen
die hier in der hundestaffel tätig ist
also ganz ganz ganz tolle frauen die
vorbilder sind so hoffe ich für viele
andere junge frauen da draußen zum
zweiten braucht es einfach wissen über
die möglichkeiten
also ich bin davon überzeugt dass viele
nicht wissen dass es im bundesheer so
durfte ich im vorgespräch erfahren über
35 lehrberufe gibt von der metrologie
über die luftfahrzeug technikerin bis
hin zur hundeführerin also das sind
alles ganz großartige möglichkeiten auch
so abseits dieses ganz klassischen
soldatinnen berufes der einem so in den
sinn kommt wenn man als bundesheer denkt
ja und zum dritten braucht es sicherlich
auch gewisse eignung sag jetzt mal des
unternehmens in dem fall der
familienfreundlichkeit es braucht auch
frauen fördernde maßnahmen und der
zusätzlichen bundesheer wahnsinnig viel
glaube das ist auch einfach ein weg den
bundesministerien plant auch als erster
verteidigungsministerin so vehement
bestreitet hier auch die
familienfreundlichkeit zu steigern wir
haben klipp gehört wir haben über 22 22
kindergruppen an 14 standorten bereits
die sommerbetreuung wird ja ausgebaut
in meinem ressort ist die familie und
beruf management gmbh angesiedelt die
auch zertifikate verteilt für die
familienfreundlichkeit von unternehmen
hier gibt es auch schon zertifikate für
das für standorte des österreichischen
bundesheers und da hoffen wir dass wir
diesen erfolgreichen weg auch weiter
gehen werden
ich bin froh dass ich mich gerade dann
hat er so eine starke kämpferin auch an
der seite weiß
und ich bin froh dass uns das in der
bundesregierung einfach so großes
anliegen ist heute das größte girls day
ist bundesweit ein tag an dem wir eben
medien auch einen einblick geben wollen
die tätigkeiten des bundes und in die
unterschiedlichen berufsfelder die hier
auch offen stehen
vielleicht eben auch sogenannte
atypische berufsfelder und ich darf mit
klaudia tanner hier heute auch die die
mädchen für das bundesheer gemeinsam
begeistern mit margarete schramböck habe
ich heute auch eine sogenannte mint
challenge ausgerollt wollen wir zeigen
dass mädchen nicht nur beim
österreichischen bundesheer sondern auch
im bereich der mathematik der technik
der naturwissenschaften gebraucht werden
und dass du ganz großartige
möglichkeiten auf sie warten und so
können wir heute unsere kräfte am girls
day um einfach mädchen und jungen frauen
alle möglichkeiten zu zeigen die die
österreichische landschaft bietet vielen
dank
sehr geehrte frau bundesministerium für
landesverteidigung sehr geehrte frau
bundesministerin mag
sehr geehrte damen und herren der presse
zunächst einmal vielen dank danke für
diese möglichkeit heute hier über meine
erfahrungen bei müsst euch im bundesheer
als frauen sprechen zu dürfen
vor über zehn jahren hat man werdegang
begonnen und ich habe mich bewusst dazu
entschieden diesen weg einzuschlagen ein
weg den wir zum damaligen zeitpunkt
einige so nicht zugetraut hätten
ich habe beschlossen soldaten zu werden
vor allem aber wollte ich mir selbst
beweisen wozu ich in der lage bin und
als vorbild dienen für andere frauen die
bis dato vielleicht noch nicht mutig
genug waren und diesen weg für sich zu
wählen mit was bedeutet dass frauen im
bundesheer zu sein was bedeute soldaten
zu sein habe ich mich von beginn an sehr
intensiv auseinandergesetzt zunächst
aber möchte ich ihnen ganz klar sagen
was es nicht bedeutet sodann zu sein
bedeutet nicht dass man eigentlich keine
frau sein möchte und deshalb einen
männerdominierten beruf ausgewählt hat
so daten zu sein bedeutet nicht dass man
sich bewusst in den vordergrund drängt
um sich vorteile zu verschaffen und
soldaten zu sein bedeutet vor allem
nicht dass man nicht bereit ist in jeder
situation das selber zu leisten kognitiv
sowie auch körperlich
frau beim bundesheer zu sein bedeutet
soldatin zu sein und diese begriff meine
damen und herren sagt einiges über
diesen beruf aus wir haben mit dem
treuegelöbnis versprochen und geschworen
das österreichische volk zu schützen und
die republik österreich mit der waffe zu
verteidigen und unserem schönen land zu
dienen das gilt für alle soldatinnen und
soldaten und somit ist eigentlich schon
vieles zu diesem beruf und zu diesem
thema frauen und bundesheer gesagt
soldaten zu sein bedeutet dass kein tag
wie der andere ist dass man jeden tag
neue herausforderungen versichert aber
auch sich in verschiedene richtungen
weiter entwickeln kann
soldaten zu sein heißt niemals alleine
zu sein und sich jeder herausforderung
mit seinen kameradinnen und kameraden
gemeinsam stellen und diese auch meisten
zu können es bedeutet in seiner funktion
für dieselbe arbeit dasselbe gehalt zu
bekommen und das meine damen und herren
ist leider noch nicht selbstverständlich
vor allem aber bedeutet das im einsatz
war das aller männer sowie frauen gleich
behandelt werden und für einen einsatz
herangezogen werden können
ich habe im auslandseinsatz im kosovo
über zwölf monate eine militärpolizei
einheit geführt welche international im
kosovo tätig wurde
ich war damals die erste frau die dieses
militärische element geführt hat und es
wurde weder national noch international
rücksicht genommen oder eine rolle
gespielt aber ich eine frau bin oder ein
mann und so war es egal ob ich eine
freude machen bin und so auch meine
soldatinnen und soldaten roms das
nationale zukommen letztes jahr am 2 11
20 20 in der nach dieses grauenhaften
terroranschlages in der wiener
innenstadt wurde ich von meinem
kommandanten auserwählt ein
militärpolizei element zu verlieren
welches rasch so rasch wie möglich in
der wiener innenstadt aktiv werden kann
und dort vor ort zu unterstützen
ich wurde nicht ausgewählt weil ich eine
frau bin noch wurde ich ausgewählt weil
kein anderer mann zur verfügung stand
mein kommentar und hat sich bewusst dazu
entschieden mir diese aufgabe zu stellen
weil eben meine damen und herren auch
eine frau der beste mann für einen job
sehen kann
auch ich unterschied nicht bei der
formierung dieses elements zwischen
männern und frauen ich unterschied
reihen nach eignung ausbildung und wer
eben die beste eigene person ist um hier
aktiv zu werden
innerhalb kürzester zeit hatte ich
dieses element formiert damit dass das
tun kann und jeder einzelne soldat und
jeder einzelne soldat entlastung kann
wozu sie ausgebildet wurden ich kann
also aus persönlichen erfahrungen im
inland im ausland und in den
dienstbetrieb sagen dass immer solche
bundes jahr gleichstellung und
gleichbehandlung gelebt werden und das
jeden tag täglich stattfindet würde mich
heute jemand fragen ob ich vor zehn
jahren noch einmal diesen weg
beschreiten würde da kann ich ihnen
heute klar und storz beantworten
vielen dank
jetzt lägen deutlich darf nun um das
kurze video bieten als lästig ist weil
vieles möglich
[Musik]
wobei ihnen damals so der beweggrund für
funktionieren also mal entscheidungen
zum bundesheer zum gen war ganz
pragmatischer ihr wollt ein arbeitgeber
mit viele möglichkeiten und ich finde
das macht genau das bundesheer aus und
weil ich im normalen dienstbetrieb mal
draußen aber ich bin aus dem
sportgymnasium raus und für mich war
wichtig dass sie den beruf eben mit
sport verbinden kann und da war es
milito perfekt
[Musik]
das kennt man den ihrer meinung nach nun
machen dass sie mehr
gerade junge
frauen hat begeistert fürs bundes die
messen sich eigentlich nur trauen viele
dem privaten trifft sind dann immer
begeistert von dem job den machen
bei der ein oder anderen merkt man dann
halt auch sie hätte es vielleicht eng
gemacht und hat sich aber vielleicht
nicht traut ist es schon nachdem er über
das man so spricht ein privaten kreis
dass man dann sagt er das ist ein
sicherer dienstgeber ist das thema
absolut so wie jetzt den leider derzeit
wie es jetzt ist es kommen jetzt aber
beobachten mit kurzarbeit und so weiter
bin ich wirklich froh an guten job zu
haben und zu wissen ok haben auch
verschiedene möglichkeiten kann mit
trotzdem weiterbilden und die kann was
aus mir machen und die möglichkeiten
sind ja nicht enden
das freut mich immer wieder zu hören
dass es mehr frauen werden aber das ist
nur ein schritt dem sehr viele weitere
folgen werden und auch folgen müssen
ich habe vor kurzem erst den frauen
förderungs plan 20.20 bis 20 23
unterschrieben und dann werden wir
vieles bieten an
kinderbetreuungsmöglichkeiten zum
beispiel auch an flexiblen
arbeitszeitmodellen wie teilzeit ich bin
überzeugt davon dass wir viele schritte
weiter kommen und wir müssen auch ein
ganz großes augenmerk legen auf viele
weibliche offiziere
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dann gericht auf nun um ihre fragen der
suche und warten bis das mikrofon bei
ihnen ist mit dem
frau ministerin herbst weitere fragen
gibt es in der bundeswehr muslims
herkunft frauen gibt es in der
bundesheer muslimische herkunft frauen
zweite frage ist diese gruppe
migrantische muslimische gruppe ist im
bundesheer haben wir haben dann ein
druckfehler gespräch mit ihnen fragen
das nicht gewünscht wird wahr welche
gründe gibt und die letzte letzter
pressekonferenz haben sie so gesagt dass
ihre presse mitunter kontaktiert ihre
presseabteilung ignoriert uns und
diskriminiert und sicht weg diese
zielgruppe welche gründe haben sie diese
jedes mal die gleiche frage stellen muss
vielen dank für die frage die mir zum
einen die möglichkeit gibt den
frauenanteil noch einmal genau
aufzuschlüsseln zunächst einmal aber
nach den dienst gaben wir haben mal mit
stand erst der april 666 soldatinnen
davon befinden sich derzeit 640 frauen
in einem dienstverhältnis 22 soldatinnen
sind im ausbildungsdienst vier frauen im
auslandseinsatz die meisten frauen in
summe sind es 294 sind als und offiziere
tätig und 93 offiziere wenn sie nach der
herkunft fragen dann ist uns auch das
ganz besonders wichtig das sieht man bei
jeder angelobung wo insbesondere die
religiösen bekenntnisse auch
dementsprechend gelebt werden der zweite
punkt ihrer frage betrifft die inserate
die werbemöglichkeiten des für einzelne
medien gibt und wie beim letzten mal
darf ich da bitten dass wir uns danach
darüber unterhalten nämlich mit meiner
presseabteilung und gibt es weitere
frage wenn es keine weiteren fragen gibt
dann darf ich sie jetzt noch zum zweiten
teil ein laden der unten im sockel hof
im innenhof des
verteidigungsministeriums stattfindet
muss die möglichkeit gibt mit anwesenden
und auch weiteren soldatinnen fotos zu
machen
sie werden dann gleich im anschluss
hinunter geleitet dankeschön